earlier you are talking about how a lot
of the money that's donated to Yale goes
toward research that furthers different
scientific developments and how a lot of
money goes toward community projects in
New Haven area so obviously a lot of the
money goes toward like social good but
do you ever feel as though like a very
successful campaign could lead to a
development of a lot of our pursuit of
luxuries that isn't sustainable at the
University Tommy first what you mean by
luxuries when just opportunities for the
students and like just to make life much
more comfortable than it needs to be
where this money could go toward some
other area I can't say in this
particular campaign that was probably
not the problem because at the same time
where we tried to raise the money we
also lost six billion dollars of our
endowment so you know there the campaign
didn't even make up for what we had lost
so we are still in a time of you know
where we have to shrink you know the
organization I think there is a
legitimate conversation to be had about
you know how much comfort you know what
is important for for a you know for a
student is it the sense of community is
it the great academics is it you know
having wonderful facilities etc I think
we can we could argue a little bit about
you know how well equipped should a
residential college be or you know I
think there are voices on both sides of
it but but at the same time in the in
our campaign we had primarily academic
goals to strengthen you know to branch
out into new areas that we didn't teach
it to secure much more financial aid
because you know we were almost fully
endowed
financial aid before the crash we spent
about 60 million dollars a year on it
and we had almost as much income from
scholarship endowment and with the
financial crash what happened is not
only you know did we lose part of that
endowment but we had much more students
who became eligible who needed it so now
we moved from 60 million a year to about
a hundred million a year in financial
aid expenditures and so we we wanted to
raise money you know for for that etc so
that campaign and the and the crash cart
off I think did not allow for this kind
of stuff to happen but I can see that we
all have to be careful and I think
student voices to be heard in that would
be good